el campo argentino paraliza sus
actividades los tractores en las calles
sirvieron para exigir cambios en la
gestión económica que afecta al sector
organizaciones de productores
agropecuarios se manifestaron en contra
de la escasez de combustible las
dificultades para la importación de
fertilizantes los altos impuestos a las
exportaciones entre otras medidas
impulsadas por el gobierno de alberto
fernández una visión equivocada de lo
que es el campo
evidentemente en sus diagnósticos
equivocados
nos lleva a una excesiva presión
impositiva a un doble mercado cambiario
que afecta a la rentabilidad queremos
que haya un ajuste lógico y valores en
el dólar que permita tener una
exportación razonable y que se genere un
marco de rentabilidad que pueda mostrar
al productor que es viable para poder
seguir el mercado cambiario de divisas
impuesto por el ejecutivo afecta también
la ganancia de los trabajadores rurales
los productores de soja reciben tan sólo
el 30 por ciento de las ganancias por su
venta debido al precio del dólar que
rige en el sector el gobierno mantiene
las restricciones las importaciones como
una solución para frenar los gastos y
debemos una está laburando para
poder comer hoy yo me pregunto queda
poca derecha
adelante tenía un margen de ganancia
marcha y que hoy no las estás teniendo
las manifestaciones se suceden en un
contexto económico complejo en las
últimas semanas el desabastecimiento de
combustible se suma la crisis interna en
la dirección del estado que derivó en la
renuncia del ministro de economía martín
guzmán y la llegada de silvina batakis
la guerra en ucrania ha sido un arma de
doble filo para el sector agropecuario
argentino
por un lado beneficiado por el súbito
aumento en el precio de los cereales y
por el otro afectado por el
encarecimiento de los fertilizantes
rusos